I'm the associate chair of the
International Affairs Council in the
Macmillan Center and this is one of the
talks in the Gattis Smith seminar series
hosted through the International Affairs
Council this series was started in 2004
and it provides an opportunity for
students to host speakers on campus so
all the speakers in the series are
people that have been invited and hosted
and have had all the arrangements done
by students who really wanted to bring
someone to campus the series honors
gatos Smith who's a retired professor of
diplomatic history and in particular it
honors his engagement with students over
the many years that he was here and also
his gift for bridging academic and the
policy arenas the student today who is
hosting this is Diana too who is a
first-year student in the master's
program in international relations
welcome everyone today I'm honored to
have the opportunity to introduce dr.
Joshua Joseph whoo taiwan's
representative to the united states
representative who assumed his position
in april two thousand seven becoming the
first democratic progressive party
member to ever take up this post the
upcoming Taiwanese presidential election
is scheduled to take place on March 22nd
2008 making them only the fourth direct
elections to ever take place in Taiwan
since political parties were legalized
in 1986 in my opinion these elections
are important and probably some of the
most important in Taiwan's political
history the future of cross-strait
relations us hyewon relations and also
both countries relations with China are
just a few of the topics representative
will address today in addition to a
career in public service representative
who is also a highly respected scholar
he graduated from national ginger
University one of taiwan's most
prestigious universities with a
bachelor's degree in political science
in 1978 he went on to obtain a PA
d in the same fields from Ohio State
University in 1989 upon returning to
Taiwan represented vu held a number of
academic positions at his alma mater
including chairmanship of the first
division of the institute of
international relations in 2002 he began
his government career as deputy
secretary secretary general Shi
President Chen shui-bian since then
representative Wu has served as chairman
of the mainland affairs council and is
now Taiwan's representative in
Washington DC which is not Taiwan's
easiest post after highly successful
careers as both a scholar and government
official he will share his experiences
with us today on the topic of Taiwan and
its unique relations with the US and
China there will be an opportunity for
the audience asked questions at the end
of the lecture so please save your
questions for the end now please join me
in welcoming representative vu in honor
of gatos Smith whom this lecture is
named after today welcome
thank you very much for the introduction
Diana and the boss that is a gentleman
I'm delighted to come to your University
probably you are used to this but for
people around the world Yale has been
one of the highest academic institutions
and for anyone who has a chance to come
over here it's really Christmas
prestigious achievement already and in
Taiwan we also have some graduates from
Young University including one of my
predecessors Fred chin and I think he
came over here or came back to the
campus last year and many people still
remember him and I hope that they'll
continue to be more and more talented
students coming to University ought to
be educated in this very excellent
academic institutions and I'm delighted
to chat with you a little bit about
something that I've been doing for quite
a while between 2004 in 2007 before I
came over here I was a chairman of the
men and affairs council I had to deal
with China for those three years and it
was difficult enough and beginning from
april last year i was appointed by the
President to head taiwan's embassy in
Washington DC and my personal experience
is more difficult than the position and
men in Affairs Council and some friends
of mine some American friends of mine
just keep joking to me that the
president of Taiwan must hate me very
much he just put me one typical job
after another but I guess that's also a
very unique experience for me to help my
hands on those preço issues that we have
to deal with either in dealing with
China or in dealing with the United
States and today I would like to share
with you some of my personal experiences
as well as a terrible policy in dealing
with both China and the United States
and I first would like to appoint out to
you some of the aspects that we consider
to be important in our relations with
the United States in the past few months
you probably read from newspapers or so
from televisions that the State
Department officials have been critical
of taiwan's government because tamil
government was considering to hold a
referendum with regard to time wash
membership in the UN under the name
taiwan and because of their criticism
and because of those criticism
newspapers and therefore many people
thought that time was relations with the
united states actually is terrible and
you know on the surface it looks so
because in the last press conference
held by Condoleezza Rice she in her
opening statement had two countries
mentioned by her one is North Korea and
another one is Taiwan and when she was
talking about North Korea in a situation
between the United States and North
Korea and about the progress of the
nuclearization issue and she said that
is making progress and when it comes to
Thailand she said that Taiwan government
is pursuing some provocative policies
and many people including Taiwan song
journalists present in the press
conference feel terrible because that
Taiwan is being compared to a rogue
state and the comments on Taiwan seem to
be a worse than a rogue state so it
gives an impression of how many US
relations have been terrible of course
it's not more in Taiwan US relations
that there's dispute in between the two
sides concerning political issues I can
tell you that the Taiwan US relations
actually are quite good when I or after
i started my service in washington DC i
have been able to get in contact with
either State Department officials or
Pentagon officials or any other
department officials or even White House
all features on a very regular basis and
I personally will tell you that I'm
probably one
the most active diplomat in Washington
DC in trying to get in contact with the
State Department officials or other
departments officials to get something
done and usually when we get in contact
with each other these kinds of things
don't go out to the press but I can tell
you that the context is very frequent
and the level context is also very high
and as far as I can see there's probably
only one or two more diplomats in a
washington DC that are just as active as
I am or more active than I am so you
know this will probably tell you a
little bit about the unofficial
officially it's unofficial relations
between Taiwan and the United States and
I can mention three several three
separate aspects to highlight the Taiwan
US relations other hand the first aspect
i would show you is the economic aspect
of Taiwan US relations even though in
the past two years old sorta one has
been arguing for free trade agreement
with the United States and it wasn't
going anywhere and maybe it was also
given a fresh impression that the Taiwan
US economic relations may not be very
good but I can tell you that they are
very good and I can give you some
figures to show you that time one and
the United States are engaged in a very
important economic relations Taiwan is a
small country what time one is the 18th
largest economy in the world and in
terms of trade Taiwan is the 16th
largest trading power of the world
despite the fact that it's a small
country but for the United States time
one ranked number 9 as a trading partner
and among all the goods trade with each
other I would say the agricultural trade
is the most important we are the number
five buyer of American agricultural
products and we're very proud of this
that Taiwan even though it's a small
country but we buy a lot
American cultural products and you
probably want to ask how much do we buy
all right let me give you some poundage
we consume on average 484 pounds of us
corn per person per year that's quite a
lot all right and 180 pounds of us
soybeans 77.6 pounds of us wheat and on
and on and on and the apples
strawberries peaches grapes and beef and
pork and these are all very important
imports in Taiwan and for the sheer
number is a number five importer of
American agricultural products but since
time when it's a small country so if you
calculate I'm per capita basis time one
is the number one importer of American
agricultural goods and we like it
because we think the American
agricultural goods are high quality and
American agricultural States also liked
it and they considered Taiwan as the
most loyal customer and we would like to
continue that kind of relations and the
first time one is also a very important
economic power that produces all kinds
of high-tech products and again I would
like to cite with you some of the
statuses of the things that we produce
we produce sixty-eight percent of
computer chips eighty-three percent of
laptops seventy-three percent of PDAs
seventy percent seventy percent of LCD
money's monitors and also some ninety
percent of motherboards and digital
cameras that is about forty percent in
there for you can see that Taiwan is a
very important producer in the high tech
area and we also sell to the United
States a lot of all of these high-tech
products some of you might have a chance
to visit Taiwan especially to us into
science park and I usually say that the
Shinto science park or other science
park in Taiwan is the extension of
Silicon Valley because you know we have
lots of
computer scientists working in Silicon
Valley about one out of every five
computer scientists in Silicon Valley
from Taiwan so you can see that that
kind of Coast connection would provide
Taiwan with a very good environment to
start and to strengthen its high-tech
industry so this is how close time one
and the US economic relations are and
another area that I would like I would
like to show you that Taiwan and the
United States are actually very good in
their relations is in the area of
security cooperation even though the
united states do not talk about this
very often and taiwan does not talk
about this very often but after i came
to Washington DC in April last year I
oversaw some military delegations are
coming to the United States for
exchanges for operations and four
agreements things like that you know
this is continue to come and also saw
groups up two groups of American
security experts even military officials
traveling to Taiwan to oversee some of
the projects that we have been working
on together and you know since this is
out of public and therefore we do not
talk about that they're frequently for
fear of Chinese racing problems in
either in Washington DC or somewhere
else but you know we try to work closer
and closer with the United States in the
security area and the United States has
been engaging in the global war against
terror and Taiwan is one of those
countries that have been working there
closely with the United States and I can
give you a couple of examples of how
closely we have been working with the
United States in this regard for public
figure Taiwan is the number three
contributor to the war in Afghanistan in
terms of humanitarian aid and
reconstruction effort and that is how
much we want to work with United States
and there's also a mechanism called
container Security Initiative
that was initiated by the US government
and they wanted the collaboration of
other governments and from the words of
the US government officials Taiwan is
the most cooperative country in this
regard and right now we have a whole
team of American experts in a kaohsiung
harbor overseeing cargoes that is coming
to the United States you know they try
to screen the car goes over there to
make sure that all the cargo is coming
to the United States is safe so we have
been working on that and we try to
explain that kind of program based upon
what we have right now so kind of one
it's a very good partner of the United
States in the many areas including a
security areas in the third area i can
show you that taiwan and the united
states have very good relations is a
more abstract abstract aspect of the
fact that time one is already a
democracy in 1997 we had the first
direct presidential election and in two
thousand we had the peaceful transfer of
power among different political parties
and this year in fact it's less than
three weeks we're going to have the
force direct presidential election ten
one is young democracy but it's
democracy and if you listen to the key
decision-makers in the United States
concerning his foreign policy expanding
and promoting freedom and democracy had
always been the backbone of American
foreign policy and I still remember in
january two thousand and let me see
january 2005 i was invited to President
Bush's second inaugural and President
Bush's keep talking about expanding
freedom and democracy how important that
is and that is the key of US foreign
policy things like that so you can see
whether he is genuine or not but at
least you know everybody was talking
about promoting human rights and
democracy and
the current Bush administration had go
into Iraq to try to build as democracy
things like this and therefore the fact
that Taiwan is already a democracy
provides the United States with a model
that he can tell other countries that
they can learn from Taiwan and for
President Bush's statement in three
separate occasions it try to highlight
this specific aspect once in proc
another time in Kyoto and anaheim in
Kimbella and he always said that the
Taiwan is a very successful model or
successful story of political
development is already a democracy and
other countries ie China should emulate
so we feel very good and the time one
was into the US interest of promoting
freedom and democracy so you can see
that Taiwan and the United States are
actually very close with each other and
when it comes to China it's a very
complicated issue you know on the US is
complicated enough on the surface you
thought that the Taiwan of us relations
are terrible and actually it's quite
good and on time one China relations you
know it's also has two stories I'm the
one and I'll tell you the good stories
first you know we have people-to-people
exchanges cultural exchanges educational
exchanges we have tourists coming from
China to visit having one and Taiwan
businessmen made investment in men in
China and you probably want to ask how
much investment we made in China is 150
billion u.s. dollars and that's quite a
lot for last year in the year before
static 671 percent of time ones total
outbound investment just go to China
just to a lot of people ask too much and
we also have about 1.2 million Taiwanese
mostly businessman living in China as
well and for the trade figures it's also
very high we used to have the United
States as that I was most important
trading partner but in the past couple
of years China has become Taiwan's
important trading partner with trade
figure has exceeded 70 billion u.s.
dollar for last year and you can see
that economic relations between Taiwan
China have become so important not just
to Taiwan but also to China and when I
was serving as a chairman of the main
interface console you know we tried very
hard to invite more Chinese to visit
have one and we try to relax our rules
and regulations so there can be more
Chinese tourists or businessman visiting
time water you know we used to be able
to allow Chinese businessman one who
want to engage in commercial activities
in in Taiwan in a group of 30 but then I
opened up the were up and before I left
I'm one there was a group of IBM
employers employees who went to Taiwan
in a group of five hundred and when they
got to Taiwan they just love the place
so this is what we tried to do and in
terms of people traveling to from china
travel into Taiwan the statuses show
that there was about 140,000 people in
the past few years annually so that's
quite a lot but to me that's still not
enough we want to open the door even
further wider so that they can be more
Chinese who have a chance to visit
Taiwan and the reason why we want to
open the door for more Chinese visitors
is because you know Chinese government
control the propaganda machines and
every Chinese people don't understand
Taiwan and for them to have a first-hand
experience on Taiwan is very important
for them to know more about Taiwan and
my personal experience or the experience
of many people who have opportunities to
engage with those Chinese visitors found
that they like Taiwan not only those
beautiful scenery places but also like
10 ones television shows and public
media and in Taiwan people already got
confused about the news report whether
that's entertaining
or it's a news report and sometimes you
know we have a evening talk shows
hosting politicians from different
political parties this is shout against
each other all the time and many people
in Taiwan just want to you know stick
their fingers in their ears and no more
no more some people but you know it for
the Chinese visitors who had it first
chance to visit Taiwan they just slap
this kinds of thing and reason is
because they don't they didn't know that
this exists in Taiwan and in addition
you know they also don't have this in
Taiwan and therefore you're an open
taiwan up to welcome the Chinese
visitors is becoming very much we will
continue to expand our room for the
Chinese visitors so in this aspect it
seems good and the Chinese government
doesn't recognize how many officials and
therefore for some things to work out we
need to have government officials
sitting together for negotiations and
beginning from 2005 we try to work
something out in a model that I
personally called Macau model that we
use NGOs in Taiwan and NGOs in China
serve as white glove and then the
government officials who would serve as
the advisors through this white glove
and therefore would allow the two sides
to sit together and the first example
was the charter flight negotiation we
started in 2005 and the negotiation was
successful and we continue to expand
based upon the Macau bottle negotiation
so this has been the good aspects of the
cross-strait relations and the negative
aspect of the Cross regulations I should
probably tell you it's very negative and
I usually describe the Crossrail
relations as a two parallel lines moving
at the same time and they never had a
chance to call course with each other
you know on the positive side is getting
seems to be getting better and better
and on the negative side is also getting
worse and worse the first is the
military rice Pentagon just released a
report on China's military yesterday and
China's military is aimed mostly at
Taiwan the best of China's military
forces is deployed along the southeast
coast areas and making time one the only
target of the Chinese military
deployment and missile is skyrocketing
is 1,000 according to pentagon static
success more than 1,000 short-range
missiles already in addition in addition
to the short-range missiles there's also
cruise missiles and other type of the
missiles and the Chinese also deployed
some rings large number of some marines
already and therefore the threat against
Taiwan has been increasing in another
area that that I many people describe us
a negative aspect of the cross-strait
relations is that diplomatic
confrontation you know China is getting
wealthier and China's getting mobile
powerful and they want to smash our
diplomatic allies every year and there
and that gets the people in Taiwan very
angry and when people get angry they try
to get the government to respond and of
course the cross-strait relations are
not going to be very good and other than
the fact that the Chinese government try
to snatch time was diplomatic allies the
Chinese government has also been trying
to keep Taiwan people out of
international activities and it's not
just visible international organizations
such as the World Health Organization or
the United Nations it's also down to a
very basic non-governmental totally
non-governmental type of international
participation and I still remember
several cases that people are entire one
just had such an uproar of what China
has been trying to do to Taiwan miss
universe beauty pagent contest it should
be non-political right none
non-political and the beauty pagent
elected in Taiwan or selected in Taiwan
let's call miss Taiwan right now its
very nature is no problem but the year
that we recorded in 2000
says that when this miss Taiwan was sent
to Panama for the miss universe beauty
patient contest at the time she was
about to us you know step step on the
stage she was forced by the organizer to
change her ribbon and that new ribbon
called miss chinese taipei and Miss hi
Juan or miss China it was in tears and
she couldn't perform and of course she'd
do well and you know this is one of them
firefighters game is a political I guess
not it's just a bunch of firefighters
trying to throw horse and try to run
around the field and do all kinds of
things to compete against each other and
in 2006 the Chinese government just
forced the organizer to change the title
of Taiwan's participation from Taiwan to
Taiwan come on China to signify a
tolerance part of China in our
firefighters participating that game
couldn't tolerate it and therefore they
just a petition against the organizer
again and again and again but to no
avail so they had to withdraw to protest
and these kinds of things just goes on
and on and on I can mention to you some
other things that you feel that that is
totally wrong for China to do that
international hairstyling contest
international pigeon racing contest why
under us what the Chinese government
tried to suppress I'm ones participation
in this totally non governmental
activities what the Chinese government
is continuing to do that and I have a
wholeness of the magical want to exhaust
all the lists because it would take
quite a lot of time but you can see
these has become one of the most
important source of conflict in between
Taiwan and China and when the Chinese
government is pressing Taiwan too hard
the honey's government of course will
respond and of course when that happens
the correlations will not be very good
by the same thing to Taiwan is the way
in the Chinese government is squeezing
Taiwan nobody's reporting about it
about when time allows and say hey
that's enough we don't want to take that
and many people started to point their
fingers and Taiwan say hey don't say
anything because that is going to make
China angry so this is the kinds of
relationship between Taiwan and China
the kind of dynamics that has been going
on and the relations completed enough
right and we thought that if the United
States can help Taiwan or other
like-minded countries that's been
described as the state officials can
continue to help Taiwan feel that we
should be safe in our international
participation but unfortunately the
United States in the last few years seem
to be in trouble itself North Korea in
Iraq and Iran and tougher and many other
countries and because the United States
has been called in those crises and very
often the US government feel that they
need to get the help from the Chinese
government since the Chinese government
is one of the five permanent members in
the Security Council in the United
Nations and that is natural and what is
not fair for Taiwan is that when they
feel that there's a need for each other
when the US government is any photo for
China to help the United States in a
time one it's been put the cyber and
it's not fair to Taiwan people because
the Chinese government seem to be
engaging in the tactics to squeeze I
want further those occasions that I
listed to you that China has been trying
to suppress taiwan's international
participation study from 2005 here it
goes on and on until today so this is a
situation we face so you can see that
the three-way relations between Taiwan
the United States and China have become
so complicated and for us it doesn't
seem you know there doesn't seem to be
an easy way out for us the United States
will completely we caught my Iran Iraq
and North Korea and Zimbabwe and
for things like this because it's a you
know international power and
responsibilities to deal with with
international issue and at the same time
in China is taking advantage of course
even want to expand it wants to grow so
China is being taking a vintage and its
power is the growing and growing and
growing and at the same time in the time
when it's a free country and therefore
people have different voices and the
time one will continue to be pointed
finger a that's been causing some
problems things like this so this is the
complicated relations and it's more
completely importance than for other
countries but i think this also one
thing that might link taiwan the united
states even other allies of the United
States in the East Asia Japan together
because the Rose the rise of the Chinese
military power have become so threatened
not just for Taiwan but also for other
countries in the region like Japan and
the United States and therefore there is
a potential for the three-way security
dialogues to upgrade to expand things
like this so in the future what tamil
government is hoping for is that you
know they can be more talks in between
chemical bourbon and the Chinese
government so there can be more
understanding more mutual understandings
more mutual trust so the
misunderstandings or calculating between
Taiwan and China can be alleviated and
we've been proposing all kinds of issues
to be negotiated and even though there
was only two issues that the two sides
of some preliminary achievements ie
child of light issue and tourism issue
but we have a whole array of issues we
hope that the Chinese government can
think about talking to Taiwan and I
think it's our hope and all sorts of
hope
the American compliment it's also the
hope of the Japanese government as along
with other governments that the
cross-strait relations can improve and
at the same time I think it's also the
hope of the Chinese people i'm not
talking about the chinese government
because they always say something else
but i think the hope of the chinese
people is that time one in China can
live peacefully with each other and the
two sides can open door for each other
and that will require the two sides to
have more opportunities we engage with
each other but each other more and i'll
stop here to take your questions I know
you must have lots of questions for me
thank you
thank you very much for this question
I'm delighted to be called ambassador in
Washington DC this is a being a very
touchy issue you know if you I'll give
you my car a little bit later doesn't
say taiwan ambassador is as a
representative the reason is because
taiwan and united states do not have
formal relations with each other but
even though the two sides have no formal
relations with each other i'm able to
function like it we all matter in our
office in washington DC can function
like a real embassy so there's no
problem in that regard and delighted
again to be called ambassador and for
Kosovo's case i guess is a bit different
from taiwan's case because Kosovo is
willing that you know big area of slack
inside rather than like Taiwan in a
Taiwan is surrounded by water and Taiwan
is not under the PRC jurisdiction ever
since nineteen forty nine when the PRC
established itself anytime one we always
say we're always self-government and
beginning from 96 we have our own
presidential election and in 1991 1992
we had our own parliamentary election
and therefore according to international
law tamil government exercises exclusive
jurisdiction over territory on this
control and this is a simple of Taiwan
being independent country you know it's
not under any country's jurisdiction so
where the time one declares independence
or not taiwan the fact is that it's not
under china's jurisdiction so this is
the fundamental difference in between
Taiwan and Kosovo and I think Kosovo's
case also allow us to have some
considerations about the different cases
the international law that ors
consideration if the United States and
major European countries and Japan
recognize the independence of Kosovo why
not taiwan and i guess it's in two
different situations and industry really
hard to apply but to us the reality is
that Taiwan is not under child's tuition
so we have more rights to be recognized
by the international community more than
the Kosovars case so this is how we feel
but i think you know Kosovo's case would
allow people to think more about the
situation related to you know
well this is very important and I'd like
to explain in this way the US government
always has in a very steady policy told
the cross-strait relations historical
after 1972 you know on the one hand they
don't want to see China use force
against Taiwan and on the other hand it
doesn't want to hear they don't want to
see Taiwan formally declare independence
or do anything that we invite the
Chinese military actions against Taiwan
and up until today this you're no
exception to the kind of policy tool
Taiwan but historically we also see a
fact that the president of the united
states or administration's in the united
states you know sometimes they would
link to one side and yep or lean toward
another side and it was very interesting
that you would mention about clinton
administration in 1995 and 1996 of when
the Chinese got very aggressive in
concert relations the United States sent
two aircraft carrier battle groups to
our region to show too
people that analysis is on Tywin side
and they also use that to show to the
Chinese government but two years after
that remember when President Clinton
went to Shanghai 3 no statement and you
know I tried time on people crazy in
order for him to redress that issue he
started to say that the future in Taiwan
us we in Taiwan China relations must be
peaceful and needs to have the same of
the town on people and we started
calling that the force pillar so you
know it comes goes back and forth in
between this two lines of interest
policy told the cultural relations and I
think it's the same with the Bush
administration started out very friendly
gestures to Taiwan but we knew all along
that President Bush must come back to
the other side sooner or later because
China is a very important player on the
international community and the
ministration has to be influenced by the
big business as a whole and the big
businesses we want to do business with
China so it's shifting back and forth
that's a historical pattern and the
complicated thing is that the United
States happened to be called first by 9
11 am-10 by North Korea and Iran and
Iraq and that forced the administration
took depend more on China so they seem
to be lean more to China in this case so
the ship seemed to be wider in
perspectives so this is a
in Taiwan and I would like to come back
to what you mentioned that the policy
special by time I seem to be provocative
and that seemed to you know chipped
Taiwan support in the united states away
but i guess for taiwan foreign policy
makers we simply could not find any
other better alternatives to deal with
the situation that china is getting more
powerful in there be squeezing taiwan
you know for example many people ask me
why should taiwan try to go for
referendum on the UN issue because that
is not going to help taiwan to enter
into the United Nations the fact that
remains clear that China has more than
140 countries recognizing it and Taiwan
only is 23 countries right now and
whenever it come down to a bold Taiwan
is going to lose it anyway but the fact
is that if we don't talk about the fact
that Taiwan has been suppressed in its
international participation by China if
we don't talk about the wh 0 issue and
if we don't talk about the fact that
Taiwan has been excluded from the United
Nations or the fact that I one is the
only country that is not any part of the
world health organization or the United
Nations you know we don't have any
chance to have other people to talk
about the rights of the time people and
I think for any democratic country to
have a render referendum is the most
peaceful most rational most democratic
way to allow people's voice heard and
you know this is what we try to do which
is want people to know that we don't
want to put up with a situation that
Taiwan it's the only country that is
being excluded from international
politics and it's being suffering
because they China had been squeezing so
this is what we try to do and I'm sure
when the United States doesn't have to
deal with all these problems anymore or
when the United States and the new
administration they probably start up
from more friendly tone to Taiwan
I what is going to have presidential
election very soon as well and the right
now many people's is pointed at the
current president in Taiwan's the only
source of problem and they just ignore
all those structural problems that i
mentioned us negative aspect of the
cross-strait relations so maybe we also
have sorry
right thank you very much for that
question I think that's an excellent
question the source of mistrust very
frequent comes from the worst and these
which don't mesh with each other you
know for all this time the Chinese
government's standard official line to
Taiwan is you know I always I always
have to do this whatever is good for the
time people they will try to do it and
try to make it successful that's the
official line of what many people in NYC
it's our room of international
participation which is very important
for Taiwan they speak squeeze further in
further and further and the Chinese
government is deploying more and more
missiles more and more some rings gear
in Taiwan and therefore the people see
different pictures and different kinds
of activities that Chinese government is
doing a 12-time wat in a created
confusion and that creates mistrust in
misunderstanding and at the same time
maybe the Chinese look at Taiwan as the
same way there in two thousand president
of Taiwan says that as well as China
doesn't have any intention to use force
against I want that one is not going to
be clear independence things like this
but in 2002 time on president suddenly
declare that time one in China are two
countries on each side of the time
straight and back
many people on China or in the United
States very nervous eek waste that
statement as a declaration of
independence so things like this will
continue to field misunderstanding or
conflict or animals or conflict in each
other's consideration but for town
government we have been ascending of the
worlds with China ever since and Men
Tony's 2002 I 20 july 2002 Chinese
government is humiliate president chain
for something that you feel that he's
been so gracious in offering Google
gestures to China and that you know turn
him around say maybe we should give up
those kinds of goodwill gestures anymore
so this becomes another source of the
Chinese misunderstanding to all time one
and as I said you know there needs to be
more people-to-people contact especially
those people who are intelligent enough
or influential enough to influence more
people and we try to invite more Chinese
to visit Taiwan students academics or
businessmen or even tourists and you
were talking about the visit that Taiwan
or restrictions that have a government
place the Chinese visitors to Taiwan and
of course you know we cannot just open
the door up and whoever wants to Elaine
it I want and they can land in Taiwan I
want to search small country and we have
border control and we are customer
service just like any other country and
since the two governments are not
talking to each other for those people
who want to visit have one either for
commercial activities or for other
purposes they need to get entry visa
from Taiwan government and usually it's
done by a travel agency said and many
people can do that without any problem
and for most cases who complain about
this as I know when I was serving as a
chairman of the menendez Council it was
a Chinese government who did not okay
the application to exit the country
either the visa application
or entry permit application I'll attend
one side from the Chinese applications
has more than seventy percent successful
rate and this rate is higher than any
country not the Chinese visitors are
going to make application form so
trained ones door is wider open than any
other country but for investments I can
tell you just one aspect we understand
that it can be very important for Taiwan
to accept the Chinese capitals when
Chinese are getting more powerful in
kannamma CLE so we try to evaluate on
those things that the Chinese government
won't use its economic cut to influence
Taiwan politically or diplomatic and the
first aspect that we identify that
you'll be good for both sides that
couples can go to each other's territory
it's the real estate Chinese can buy a
piece of land but they cannot move at
any weight so it should say so we open
up that but we open up in 2003 but there
were limited cases as far as I know
there won't 12 applications and the
actual success was only three cases and
that we try to study why the Chinese are
not coming and the reason it's very
simple the Chinese government still
control the Capitals outfit and when the
capital outflow is from China to taiwan
for real estate the Chinese company
simply won't approve it so I think that
you know it's as easy as that but you
know in order for the two sides to have
more economic activities with each other
for example for Chinese banks to come to
10 14 operation or for Chinese capitals
who come to Taiwan or other type of
investment or more families Carol's you
will go to China or other type of equal
activities it needs the two sides to sit
down together to work out some deals you
know we sign all kinds of the economic
deals with other countries and we hope
that China can sign economic deals with
us and several aspects of this courtesy
exchange we do a lot of business with
each other but revving v + NT are not
convertible to each other and of course
it's their chosen for businessmen who
have to come back and forth and in order
for the two currencies to be able to
convert to each other's currencies the
two sides need to sit down together to
work out that agreement but so far the
Chinese government is not willing to do
that and of course our pens in time all
wants to go to China for investments and
the Chinese thanks also want to go to
that one for investment and in order for
anything anywhere in the world to have a
chance to go out of the country to do
investment it needs to have the power of
the or the home country needs to have
the power of overseeing the financial
activities or something we call
financial supervision and in order for
financial supervision to take place
there has to be negotiations in between
the two governments for an agreement but
so far the Chinese government still
doesn't want to do it so in order for
the two sides of the talin straight to
have a more healthy type of economic
relations there's so many issues that
the two sides need to sit down together
and if you like to see that I think we
need to start purging China to be more
courageous in stepping forward to import
it with time one those economic issues
like what they did with
I try to fly or tourism issues again
apologize for very long answer for your
show person they're straightforward
question and used to be trained as a
political scientist in American Academy
institutions and for political scientist
even though the question is very simple
and you know we always come up with a
very complicated very comprehensive type
of answer and for this question what I
can say is that the real test in war is
war itself you know there's no pre-war
gambiae can really tell what will happen
but either cross-strait relations I can
tell you that China is becoming much
more powerful nowadays than before it
has so many missiles it has so many jet
fighters it's so many summer rings but
in a real war situation it may not be as
simple as China lobbyists missiles at
Taiwan and then saying a bunch of people
to take it over and then you know Taiwan
it's gone now it says it will never be
that simple because time one also has
power to counteract we also has a very
strong air force and we also have some
other type of abilities and remember we
had four key class destroyers from the
United States just couple of years ago
in our gaming or our simulations those
four key class destroyers proved to be
very important in Taiwan's or scenarios
with United States and of course it is
probably not Taiwan alone who is
engaging in combat activities with China
they will probably be other actors so
once were stars you know you won't be
that simple I think we need to take Iraq
that's a very good lesson
when the President Bush says that I want
smack Saddam Hussein out it could do
that but you know why we decided to see
that the story is different and
therefore we need to keep in mind that
the war may not be that simple besides
or may not be good for Taiwan people and
may not be good for the Chinese people
and I think it's always the objective of
the town government to try to see if the
two sides can sit down together and work
out a peace deal peace should be good
for Taiwan and should be good for China
complex relationships three-way
relationship ack from the military for
the flitter phone hey you also mentioned
your painting an election coming up just
a very well and i won as is the case in
the United States it may be that a
different party I will now come forward
and power I was wondering if you could
summarize for us going into the election
now what are the different official
positions of the major parties on this
issue of unification with China
good I'm very well that you are not
asking me the embarrassing question
whether I get to stay in Washington DC
the two political parties are actually
very different in your organization and
very sorry and it'll came he was the one
who moved the Nationalist government to
Taiwan in 1949 so it always trace its
roots back to China and it has its
ideology based upon is traditional
Chinese connections and the DPP on the
other hand was a domestic grown
opposition movement democratic movement
and therefore what the DPP has or its
vision is always a democratic
democratization of Taiwan so the two
political parties are very different and
because of this difference you know it's
easy to identify the supporters of the
two political parties on the one hand is
more independence oriented of Taiwan on
the TPP side and on the other hand is
more of a unification oriented and when
the election were all so long all these
kinds of positions started to get they
in the reason is because the population
distribution the unification and
dependence issue is a very well
structured bell shape the majority of
the people are in the middle we did
surveys all the time
the manifest comes with other
institutions or other poor organizations
and it always proved that the majority
of the people are in the middle they
want to maintain status quo and
therefore you see that the candidates
shifted their positions gradually toward
the middle and I still remember that in
January 2006 when the mind Joe a former
mayor former chairman of the county
visited Europe and it was coming some
implication issue he was saying that the
kmt Saudi McCall is unification with
China and candy needs to actively create
conditions for unification in the future
and you know so many things that
surprise a lot of people but that is
what they believe in all along mr. mind
you even say that the arms procurement
from the United States is activities
engaging in arms race with China so you
can see that the elections started heat
up you know they show their true face
but when the election was alone you know
they always cover up and they just
wanted to present selves as in the
middle of the voters no independence no
unification no use of force and all
these kinds of things they just want to
catch the middle of majority it's the
same can be applied to the DPP people
know that the TPP just want to maintain
the current status that Taiwan is not
ruled by China and people are not
interested in talking about unification
was China but at the current stage the
TPP candidate is also talking about me
or having a charter flight expanded into
direct line and they want to have more
economic relations between the two sides
things like this so their positions look
awfully similar and that leads to a
conclusion that political parties in
Taiwan or casual parties something that
we've been arguing all along you know
that's really no differences in their
agenda but on the unification issue
alone you can see that they come from
very different big ones thank you
let me answer the last part of your
question first because that is very
interesting in Japan understand much
more about the dynamics in between
Taiwan and China than many other
countries and when it comes to the
referendum question here no one in Tokyo
coming on this issue because the
Japanese government's official position
is that this is up to the two sides of
the town straight to talk to each other
and it's not something that for the
Champions Cup into coming on and
especially when even if the referendum
passed is not going to increase the
possibility of Taiwan entering into the
United Nations and therefore China Japan
is not going to make any comment so this
is official Japanese position in this
regard and in the past few years I
noticed that the Japanese government is
getting more and more nervous of China's
rise especially military rise together
was the potential of the Chinese
government using nationalism against
China against Japan I'm sorry you know I
was in Japan several times in between
2004 and 2007 and I think 2005 is
particularly interesting because that
was a year there were many anti-japan
demonstrations in China and one of them
just warm into the Japanese embassy and
destroy not embassy but the consulate in
shanghai and the cost a lot of damage
and the japanese people in the japanese
government just feel that that is going
too far and the chinese just
demonstrated it's a negative phase
towards Japan and therefore you can see
that from that point on the Japanese
government study this shift is a
position it taught taiwan and china
china it has studied to encourage more
japanese tourists to visit i want rather
than china the chinese tourists stop not
still not totally stopped but decreased
significantly and the japanese studied
to have more dialogues with taiwan and
you know we are having the more the
better relations with Japan ever since
then but one fact remains even though
the relations between her on in Japan
improves in a course of last few years
but it doesn't lead to a situation where
time one in Japan can enjoy the kind of
relations we enjoy with the United
States we can we still cannot engage in
the military cooperation because that is
still something that is too sensitive to
the Japanese government to the
the Chinese cameras for that engage in
the military alliance with another
country and they will describe as a
missile defense system as an alliance
building process they will use force
against Taiwan and the war the Japanese
government certain that if they are too
close to Taiwan there might be
counterproductive so they end in
political dialogues with each other and
so far we join directed political
dialogue relations with champagne I
already talked about how emotionally
limited international participation
participation is that's coming to people
but I'm just wondering how much real
damage that has done to the Taiwan I
guess it doesn't know more damage to
protocol against rhetoric of any
dependents then economy but like how
much did it the feeling of being again I
suppose that's a standard political
scientist question want to know the
detail the exact type of things and
again I'll try to answer in a particle
scientist way try to cite you with some
specific evidence so you understand that
it's closing time one tremendously i
remember in 2003 that they were stars
his taiwan china singapore hong kong and
many other countries because 10 one is
not a member of the wh 0 and therefore
wh 0 couldn't send any expert to Taiwan
to helped our government to deal with
the situation so we were left alone to
deal with the Sarge crisis and even
though we continue to go through
different countries to urge the wh 0
secretariat to send experts at I want to
help town gullible but the Chinese
government continue to tell the wh 0
security area that you cannot because
Taiwan is under very good care of the
Chinese government so you know it
continues to hold this position so the
wh 0 couldn't stand any expert until
there was a major hospital
outbreak in Taiwan called herping
hospital piece hospital and it's been
broadcast live on talent television
people saw that the nurses and doctors
were quarantined in the hospital they
opened up the window I say we want to go
out we don't want to die in here and
that created a national panic and we
thought that probably is no end to this
Sarge crisis and the wh 0 expert decided
that they need to send someone to Taiwan
so that was the first time the wh 0 was
engaged in contact with Taiwan and
despite the fact that the whot wanted
the same for experts with time one they
got very clear instructions I work in
the presidential office at the time so I
still remember the wh 0 X percent to
Taiwan had a very clear instructions
from the wh 0 secretary that they should
not talk to time one health officials
who were fighting SARS at the time so
you can see this is really costing time
want something and the kwame Costas is
terrible and the psychological cost is
even higher I still remember that we had
to aware mass at the time we cannot
shake hands with each other at the time
the whole nation is in panic and people
were saying that we wouldn't have to
face this if we were a member of the wh
0 and I think the Chinese were not smart
enough or they are not considerate
enough to the town people at the time
went on was trying to fight stars there
was wh 0 assembly in Geneva in May 2000
2003 the Chinese government official
says that how people cannot get into the
WHL it's not legal and it's not right
things like this and one official even
turn around to accounting report says
that don't care about you so this kind
of thing hurt Taiwan people and I think
it costs more than the physical damage
on Taiwan is also called rift in the
relations between Taiwan
and of course I one is metro chinese
been done with this highlights new
generations to generation and the
generation twenties and the generation
during childhood with regard to child
actor of a more than understand the new
newborn babies you know kids my age
migrant families so with an accountant
indication of future channel even the
New Democratic composition of Taiwan and
China generation to generation marriages
and stay in Taiwan well i think you know
it's a natural way of development either
relations in between Taiwan and China we
don't discourage nor do we encourage the
mixed marriages in between the Townies
me and Chinese women it happens to be
that way but we don't we don't
discourage it and or do we encourage it
and the government what the government
tried to do in Taiwan is with a very
clear understanding that the chosen of
these next marriages might have
difficulties in their education because
most of these mixed marriages come from
a mortise and village social strata and
what we try to do is to over education
opportunities to these youngsters and in
addition to more benefits or more
incentives for these youngsters I think
we also try very hard to provide
additional opportunities for these men
and spouses because you know
when they came to Taiwan they need to
understand more about Taiwan they need
to learn the way telling people live in
all kinds of things so you know which I
do provide that kind of opportunities as
well in addition to the mixed marriages
between Taiwan and China there are also
mixed marriages in between Taiwan and
Vietnam Taiwan and Indonesia and you
know we try to provide similar kinds of
incentives so that those mixed marriages
can you know live in the mainstream time
telling society without any problem and
the government to spend so much money on
this program and you're right that the
composition of the newborn baby coming
out of coming out of the mixed marriages
is proportional various is getting
higher and higher and higher as far as i
remember one out of every seven chosen
newly born chosen are from mixed
marriages and I think mixed marriages
was China is a majority of this of this
part and by year 2010 one out of every
five chosen were born out of this mixed
marriages but will it do any systemic
change to time wants a political
structure in the long run I doubt it you
know look at the United States look at
new york it was visited yesterday look
at texas or california in a day so much
foreign population coming to these
different regions and become American
citizens do they change the basic
features of the United States or
California a great state I don't think
so Taiwan is already created a democracy
a very open society
and it's a pro list achsah ciety and
therefore mixed marriages just enriched
time one's a protocol culture and I
think it's good for Taiwan and in some
sense that's better than japan japan is
have more to homogeneous and therefore i
don't think that is going to create
problems for taiwan many people in
Taiwan or eat in this aspect that the
many Chinese spouses maybe they are more
for the unification in the future but in
our statistics you know it doesn't
really show up this way so we shouldn't
worry about
what I hope to in Taiwan is it's
probably very much like the United
States will be talking about recruiting
younger generation into politics but
it's always a mixture of order
generation and younger generation
president chain when he was elected it
was not yet 50 years old we will
describe him as a young generation I
don't know because they see me involved
in politics for a long time and you know
one of the most prominent foreign policy
adviser on the PPP site is called beacon
shop and she was not yet 40 she looks
very much like you it looks very young
and she's very intelligent but she the
younger representation of the younger
generation so because if she's been
helping the DPP or more long on the KMT
sign look at my new job this young and
handsome and almost as handsome as I am
but is he really a representative of a
young generation or you know he is going
to represent the fact that the KMT has
transformed itself into the under
political party probably not as far as I
know kmt under the leadership of or mind
Joe when he right now tries to dominate
his own campaigning he tried to instill
try to distance himself from the party
headquarters because in his mind party
headquarters is still being controlled
by a bunch of oligarchs or the old
politicians so they they don't get along
remember the entire visited China 2005
but that kind of action was not your
door
so there were differences but in order
for any political party in Taiwan to be
viable in history mixture of the younger
generation and order generation and I
think one of the very important thing in
Taiwan is that each particle party
understand the importance of having
young a lot come into the politics you
know they always have that youth
division and they work very hard to
create environment for younger people to
feel close to that political party
that's a situation very similar to the
United States your personal what do you
think will happen in 5 10 15 years to
taiwan now that you hope will happen
will happen I was just joking with some
journalists in New York last night that
in any open setting I can I have any
personal opinion anything I say just
represent our government but I'm more
open than the voice of the county for me
and I'm willing to give you some of my
observations and these observations are
based upon my experience in doing
academic research in time one or doing
Taiwan China relations between 2004 in
2007 the way I understand is that time
one is probably will remain the way it
is because the development seem to be
more mature nowadays there will always
be two political parties competing
against each other or two teams
competing against each other and
especially after the change of the image
system 2005 was the first election in
January this year I think the two
political parties are here to stay and
it will remain this way for a long time
to come and especially with the KMT
majority in the parliament it becomes
very difficult to change all kinds of
the rules of the games anymore so taiwan
what you see nowadays will probably be
taiwan what you will see in 10 20 30
years and will continue to be a
democracy taiwan's economy even though
it might not grow as fast as china's or
other newly rising economies but i think
i was the economy will continue to
perform quite well compared to other
mature economies so this is what I
understand about hang one but I think
one of the more interesting aspect of
this is you know what is a cross-leg
relations going to be like in 10 years
20 years 20 years and when I was in a
minute of his house or people just ask
me these hypothetical questions I have
the right to remain silent when FS these
questions but I always try to explore
about this and the answer is answer I'm
not sure what it's going to turn out to
be and the uncertainty is associated
with China's development if China's
growing economic that's fine that's you
know to everybody's benefit but there
are some certain problems associated
with China's economic development
because it's inequitable distribution in
coastal areas is much better than the
areas in agricultural sector is
temporary despite the fact that
commercial area is rising very rapidly
and of course one of the most important
aspect of development is that when
people have more money but you don't
have a better education more
international exposure the next thing
they want is to have more freedom to
have better quality more responsible
more responsive type of government and
that was the experience that we went to
retire one it was the same experience in
South Korea and many other new be
democratized country so that is probably
going to be the process of the Chinese
development is going to go through
sometime down the road and we have
already seen indicators in China that
maybe people want to do more than just
economic growth there more churches
leaders even though their jail and can
continue to be more church leaders
advocating religious freedom continuing
to be dissident riders on the Internet
despite the fact that they're more of
them being jailed there are journalists
who are willing to engage in
investigative type of reporting even
though many of them as you're in jail
they're human rights lawyers in China
nowadays who want to defend the Chinese
people even though many of them are in
jail right now so you see this kind of
thing studied to a mushroom and I think
it's an environment for us to see that
there may be optimistic environment for
the Chinese people too
for a bit of oddity and I think one more
thing that is quite important it is the
demonstration activities in China in
what people feel that they suffer
because of some certain things they just
pull out on the street and try to demand
compensation things like this and I
think that's the beginning of the people
to be aware of their self-interest and
of course awareness of self-interest is
a beginning of freedom and democracy so
we see indicators that China might go
through change as well but one danger
that we see in this process of change is
that in the process of change any
authoritarian government might tempted
to find a scapegoat in order to divert
the domestic attention or in order to
keep the country together and that is
something that we worry about that time
on my account a scapegoat
I it is necessary that you know Taiwan's
flight service including financial and
communication actually want to go out
and child after all channels of huge
bodies but the fact you know
the most important value is now is that
child is that Taiwan government put a
lot of vegetation expand it especially
event on financial industry which one
which one wants to just you know i have
a small example that is that high one
which very much wanted to be back in
China because most of its customers
transfer to China but you should know
how limitation we could we couldn't do
that but finally we found yoga with
bypass the vegetation stand by our
endowment the series of environment
family think they went to China and
better just my question is that cause I
would like to have your clothes
or child for high one and you know that
is along with the chamber acknowledge
and garments no more and more economic
well thank you very much for that
question there are two parts in your
question the first part or your
statement before you ask the question
even the first part of your statement is
concerning time once a long investment
to China are you write that it's so much
investment coming from taiwan to china
and most of the manufacturer are going
to china mostly china to take advantage
of cheaper labor and other more other
conditions that would reduce the
production costs but i think that the
factories are changing it's not a set
condition that things don't change in
the past year or so you can see that the
chinese government is adopting
regulations or rules or laws that will
start anything benefiting the labors and
they will also start to apply
restrictions on the production which we
got to the pollution and that is
increasing the cost or the manufacturer
industries in China and many Koreans are
migrating out because the Koreans just
like tony's whistling are trying to take
a take advantage of the lower production
costs in China and it's the same was the
Taiwanese investment in China we already
started seeing the process became a
couple of years ago but I think it's
going to intensify the reason is what I
just say that the production cost is
getting higher and higher and higher
they might not necessary all move back
to Taiwan but they try to find places
where they can still find cheaper labor
and one of the destination is Vietnam in
another way they try to do is to move
further inland to cheap areas or to poor
areas so that the cost of labor is still
very low sodium this is probably semi
encouraged my Chinese government
officials as well so we see this kind of
process taking place and except for
those high-tech investment in China most
of the time I see investment in China
are actually those are small and medium
type of production and I think they are
adaptable and they are also flexible
whenever they feel that they cannot make
a buck in China anymore they can always
find some other places that is can still
make profits so this is the situation
that we see with regard to tan ones
investment in China and the second is
Terrance financial institutions and the
limitations you feel that its place and
I and I try to touch upon that minute
ago that the Chinese government with
won't negotiate with time one to allow
time well thanks to operate in China and
I think you ask the right people because
I personally was in charge of some of
this there were several divisions in a
financial institutions anywhere in the
world one is insurance and one is stock
market and another one is the banking
operations we opened up the stock market
operations in china want to investment
make investment in china for stock
brokerage things like this and they
initially thought that talented woman is
pulling hard and when I came to the
manifest has all implemented for that
was the first issue I encounter which we
got to town investors who want to go man
China and say what there's no reason to
stop you go check with the Chinese
officials that Taiwan government under
the leadership of ontology is now open
the brats stock brokerage so you know
the guy the president of taiwan stock
brokers association went to china and
talk to the Chinese government officials
and came back with some words that right
now they want to you know they want them
to sign mou with China to facilitate
that process and wasn't fine go ahead
decided and so they went to China again
in convicted Chinese want to hit more
more time they need longer process in
order for that in order to be authorized
and after several times they realized
that it was the Chinese government a
time when its government who is making a
stop I'm there in this many men in China
you know we already fully open up their
investment in mainland China and our
banking operations in china is it's
similar story the Chinese kaboom
continue to say we work on the Taiwanese
banks to operate in Taiwan a we also
want to operate in they welcome our
veins to operate in China and they also
want to operate in Taiwan and they start
and the bankers in one so inquiry for
that they can just go but for any
banking institutions anywhere in the
world for them to operate in another
country financial supervision is a
necessity because we don't want the bank
institutions to go sour we don't want
institutions to fail because the
government will eventually arpita want
to build up their guard and therefore
Financial Supervision agreement is
always been signed among different
countries different countries signed
that agreement with China the only
exception is Japan and even Japan
doesn't have that specific agreement but
there were tested understandings and
memorandum saying that the Japanese
government will need to send supervisors
to supervise their banking institutions
in China so it's almost equivalent to an
agreement of a Financial Supervision but
up until today the Chinese government
shown no interest in talking to taiwan
on the financial supervision
he raised this notion of flexible
participation to be labeled necessarily
as Taiwan in that way we would not
create more hardship for telling people
and at least get ourselves in first now
I understand that of course is daemon
from the opposite party and you have
totally different ideology whatsoever
but don't you think that if the grill
goal really is to the Taiwanese people's
voice to be heard a flexible way would
be better to at least make the
possibility a possibility instead of
going down a row the only that it did
that lock because what we see from the
stars incident you rent about that we
age old question after all the
stubbornness from both governments it's
the people who are ultimately stop
bernal both governments with which
government taiwan and china well I
thought we are the one who wanted their
there to participate in the world health
organization you know we try to be
flexible on the World Health
Organization first US health entity
would try to play down the sovereignty
part and we don't try to apply us member
you know we only try to apply as
observer but he take us anywhere so
flexibility main de necessary bring good
results and it's very interesting that
you would race what mr. ma was
commenting on that we need to flexible
maybe this and that and that and that
but I think when it comes to the heart
political decision we need to raise
something for the people to make a
decision on and do you know the
referendum question proposed by the KMT
side
we need to re-enter the United Nations
under the name Republic of China or
anything appropriate and to me that's
not a referendum question at all it is
all inclusive it covers everything and
therefore this can you know no answer no
to that question so I think for
Responsible protocol times we need to
show a way for the country to go and I
think for the people you got would you
know we have been trying for so many
different ways here in the past fews
past seven eight years in our wh 0
participation or in our you and
participation we try there is things in
participating un activities and we even
try something called peace propose or
peace resolution in the UN and nothing
is moving on and reason is because China
can have so many diplomatic allies to
pull out by oneself participation in
either the wh 0 or UN so we need to you
know show to the time people that
there's one way for the people to go and
that is what the DPP has been trying to
do and I think if the KMT is elected
into the presidency if to me that's
going to be unfortunate because I might
lose my job I think the came he will do
quite a lot of things that is very
similar to the DPP government and
especially with regard to the cross
relations I took over in two thousand
voir sur chairman of the main NFS
Council and when I compare my notes my
speeches my statement with my
predecessor immediate predecessor who is
also a DBP there's no difference of
course that's not surprising but when i
try to compare my nose my speech and my
statements with my predecessors
predecessor with kmt we find i found
surprisingly awfully similar as well and
mayor mind Joe even though he's been
talking about all these ideas new ideas
talk about change some like
American candidate you know but he used
to serve as a deputy chairman of the men
and Affairs Council in 1991 and 1992 and
try to dig up all his old statements
even the newspaper reports about what he
said and compare his statements with my
statement in between 2004 2007 they are
almost identical so you don't expect any
change for any kmt future future county
administration on those are major issues
and any things will remain the same and
the reason why things will remain the
same or policies will remain quite
similar to what we have been pursuing
it's because the basic structure it's
the same you know on the one hand we
have a very good economic relations
people-to-people exchange and I'll be
outta here china has continued to climb
down on taiwan in taiwan's international
participation in our the other hand
China's military continue to rise and
these will serve as a negative aspect
and this is a structure that will
dominate Taiwan's political
decision-making concerning cross-strait
relations and that will also affect imus
relations with the United States again
thank you very much for listen to me
you